Before I begin today,
I thought I would take the
first five minutes and show you
some fun stuff I have been
hacking on for the past three
years.
This has to do with 6.002 and
circuits and all that stuff,
but this is completely
optional, this is for fun,
this is to go build your
intuition, this is to check your
answers, whatever you want.
This is not a required part of
the course.
Just for fun.
There is this URL out here that
I put down here.
I have been hacking on this
system for the past three years,
and for the first time this
year and very tentatively and
gingerly introducing it to
students.
The idea here is that it is a,
that is kind of defocused.
Any chance of focusing that a
little bit better?
The idea of this is that it is
a Web-based interactive
simulation package that I have
pulled together.
And what you can do is you can
pull up a bunch of circuits.
Notice that the URL is up here.
It is
euryale.lcs.mit.edu/websim.
And there is the pointer to it.
So you have a bunch of fun
things you can play with.
And we have gone through all of
these things in lecture.
Let's pick the MOSFET
amplifier.
You come to this page.
This is something you have seen
in class.
And let's play with this little
circuit.
And you see the mouse?
Good.
You can set up a bunch of
parameters.
You can set up the MOSFET
parameters VT and K.
You can set up the value of R
for your resistor,
you can establish a bias
voltage, and you can have an
input voltage vIN.
So you can apply a bunch of
input voltages.
You can apply a zero input,
unit in pulse,
unit step, sine wave,
square waves.
Or this was the part that took
me the longest to get right.
You can also input a bunch of
music.
And so far I just have two
clips, so you are going to get
bored listening to them.
Good.
So you can also input music.
And what you can do is you can
watch the waveforms,
you can listen to the output
and do a bunch of fun stuff.
One experiment I would love for
you guys to try out.
Again, remember,
this is completely optional.
Just for fun.
You can apply some input.
Step input, for example,
to an RLC circuit and spend 30
seconds thinking about what
should the output look like.
I divine that the output should
look like this and then do this
and see if what you thought was
correct.
And it's fun to kind of play
around with it.
Let me start with,
just as an example,
let's say I input classical
music.
And let us say I would like to
listen to the output here that
is the voltage at the drain
terminal of the MOSFET.
For listening it sets up a
default timeframe to listen to,
so you go ahead and do it.
This shows you the time domain
waveform of a clip of the music
and then you can listen to it.
Lot's of distortion,
right?
As you can see,
there is a bunch of distortion.
And that is as you expect
because the peak-to-peak voltage
is 1 volt, the bias is 2.5,
and so this is clipping at the
lower end, plus the MOSFET is
nonlinear.
You can play around with a
bunch of things and you can have
a lot of fun.
And the reason I created this
is that MIT is putting a bunch
of its courses on the Web.
And one of the hottest things
about courses like this is the
lab component.
If you are beaming a course to,
say, a Third World country or
something, how do you get people
to set up the massive lab
infrastructure?
I know you hate your
oscilloscopes,
I know you hate your wires,
I know you hate the clips,
but the fact is you have them.
I know a lot of places those
are way too expensive to pull
together, which is why I have
been creating this Web-based
kind of interactive laboratory
so that people can learn this
stuff over the Web.
Let's go do another example
very quickly.
Let's say you learned about,
well, let's do RC circuits.
Here is the parallel RC
circuit.
And you can set up capacitor
values, resistor values,
you can set up input.
Here, let me look at the time
domain waveform for the voltage
across the capacitor.
And this time around let me
play a unit step.
And let's see what the output
is going to look like.
You can think in your minds
what should the output look
like, and then you can go and
plot it.
There you go.
That's what the output looks
like.
So you can play around with it
and have fun.
That's all the good news.
The bad news is that so far I
just have one Pentium III
machine behind us.
It is a Linux box,
so don't all of you try it at
once.
However, what I have also done,
and that took me another six
months of hacking in the small
amount of time professors have
to hack on stuff,
I've hacked an incredibly
elaborate cashing system so that
once anyone in class tries out
some combination of parameters
it goes and squirrels away all
the outputs.
If anybody else types in the
same sets of parameters it will
just get all the output and play
it back to you.
So if enough of you play with
over time, we may end up cashing
all the important waveforms and
music clips and all of that
stuff.
I have allocated a few
gigabytes of storage,
so I am hoping that it may
work.
Go forth.
Play with it.
And this is completely my
fault, so if there are any bugs
or anything simply email them to
me.
This is the first time this is
coming alive so bear with it.
Now let me switch back to the
scheduled presentation for
today.
All right, hope and pray that
this works.
Yes.
Good.
I am going to do today's
lecture using view graphs.
And the reason I am going to do
that and not do my usual
blackboard presentation which I
way, way, way prefer to a view
graph presentation.
The only reason I am going to
do this for today,
and maybe one more lecture,
is that there is just a huge
amount of math grunge in this
lecture.
What I want to do is kind of
blast through that,
but you will have it all in the
notes that you have,
so that you don't waste time in
class as you watch me stumbling
over twiddles and tildes and all
that stuff.
The key thing here is that the
insight is actually very simple.
The beginning and the end are
connected very tightly and very
simple.
There is a bunch of math grunge
in the middle that we are going
to work through and,
again, follows a complete old
established pattern.
So, in that sense,
there is really nothing
dramatically new in there.
Let me spend the next five
minutes reviewing for you how we
got here, what have we covered
so far and set up the
presentation.
The first ten view graphs I am
going to blast through and just
tell you where we are in terms
of LC and RLC circuits.
I began by showing you this
little demo, two inverters,
one driving.
I can model the inductance here
with a little inductor,
the capacitor of the gate here.
And recall that when I wanted
to speed this up by introducing
a 50 ohm smaller resistance,
I got some really strange
behavior.
Just to remind you,
for Tuesday's lecture it would
help if you quickly reviewed the
appendix on complex algebra in
the course notes.
Remember all the real and
imaginary j and omega stuff?
It would be good to very
quickly skim through that.
It is a couple of pages.
Remember this demo?
And the relevant circuit that
is of interest to us is this one
here.
It is the resistor,
there is the inductor and there
is a capacitor.
This is Page 3.
I am just going to blast
through the first ten view
graphs.
It is all old stuff.
Then we observed the following
output.
We applied this input at VA and
we got this output,
a very slowly rising waveform
because of the RC transient.
And because of that you saw a
delay.
Notice that this delay was
because of the slowly rising
transient.
This waveform took some time to
hit the threshold of the
neighboring transistor.
So we say ah-ha,
let's try to speed this sucker
up by reducing the resistance in
the collector of the first
inverter.
And so I had this input.
Now, to my surprise,
instead of seeing a nice little
much higher and much faster
transitioning circuit,
well, I did see a much faster
transitioning circuit but I got
all this strange behavior on the
output that I was interested in.
And because of that,
if these excursions were low
enough, I could actually trigger
the output and get a whole bunch
of false ones here because of
these negative excursions which
should not really be there.
That was kind of strange.
In the last lecture we said
let's take this one step at a
time.
Let's not jump into an RLC
circuit.
Let's go step by step.
Let's start with an LC,
understand the behavior.
We started off with an LC
circuit of this sort,
and using the node equation we
showed that this was the
equation that governed the
behavior of the circuit.
And then we said that for a
step input and for zero initial
conditions, that is the zero
state response,
let's find out what the output,
the voltage across the
capacitor looks like.
And so we obtained the total
solution to be this.
And there was a sinusoidal term
in there.
And the omega nought which was
one by square root of LC.
And this was the circuit.
And so for this step input
notice that the output looked
like this.
So far an input step I had an
output that went like this.
Notice that it is indeed
possible for the output voltage
to actually go above the input
value VI.
This is kind of non-intuitive
but this can happen.
So this waveform jumps up and
down.
But the steady state value,
on average if you will,
is VI.
On the other hand,
it does have sinusoidal
excursions and this kind of goes
on because there is nothing to
dissipate the energy inside that
circuit.
By the way, the fact that the
capacitor voltage shoots above
the input voltage is actually a
very important property.
We won't dwell on it in 6.002,
but just squirrel that away in
your brain somewhere.
I promise you that some time in
your life you will have to
create a little design somewhere
that will need a higher voltage
than your DC input.
And you can use this primitive
fact to actually produce a DC
voltage higher than you are
given, and then use that
somehow.
In fact, there is a whole
research area of what are called
DC to DC converters,
voltage converters.
Let's say you have 1.5 volt
battery, a AA battery,
but let's say a circuit needs
1.8 volts.
The Pentium IIIs,
for example,
needed 1.8 volts.
And the strong arm is another
chip that required 1.8 volts a
few years ago,
but the AA cell was 1.5 volts.
How do get 1.8 from 1.5?
Well, you have to step it up
somehow.
And this basic principle where
the voltage can jump up above
the input is actually used,
of course with additional
circuitry, to kind of get higher
voltages.
It is a really key point that
you can squirrel away.
This was pretty much where we
got to in the last lecture.
This starts off the material
for today.
What we are going to do is take
that same circuit,
but instead we are going to put
in this little resistor here.
This is what we set out to
analyze.
And for details you can read
the course notes Section 13.6.
The green curve here was the
behavior of the LC circuit.
And what we are going to show
today is that the moment we
introduce R this sinusoid here
gets damp.
It kind of loses energy.
And I am going to show you that
the behavior is going to look
like this.
By introducing R this guy
doesn't keep oscillating
forever.
Rather it begins to oscillate
and then kind of loses energy
and kind of gets tired and
settles down at VI.
And remember the demo.
This is exactly what you saw in
the demo.
You had a step input and you
had this funny behavior.
And for the RLC that is exactly
what it was.
So today's lecture will close
the loop on what you saw in the
demo and the weird behavior,
and I am going to show you the
mathematics foundations for that
today.
Let's go ahead and analyze the
RLC circuit.
I purposely created the entire
presentation to follow as
closely as possible both the
discussion of the RC networks
and the LC networks so that the
math is all the same.
Exactly the same steps in the
mathematics are in the
exposition of the analysis.
What's different are the
results because the circuit is
different.
So don't get bogged down or
whatever in the mathematics.
Just remember it is the same
set of steps that you are going
to be applying.
We start by writing down the
element rules for our elements.
Nothing new here.
For the inductor V is Ldi/dt.
The integral form which is
simply 1/L integral vLdt=i.
We saw this the last time.
And for the capacitor,
the current through the
capacitor is simply Cdv/dt.
Those are the two element rules
for the capacitor and inductor.
The element rule for the
resistor, of course,
is V=iR.
You know that.
And for the voltage source we
know that, too,
the voltage is a constant.
Just follow the same
established pattern.
By the way, just so you are
aware, I have booby trapped the
presentation a little bit to
prevent you from falling asleep.
You see the dash lines here?
Whenever you see a dash line,
that stuff needs to be copied
down.
Don't trip over that.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
We start by using the usual
node method.
And I have two nodes in this
case.
Unlike the LC circuits,
I have two unknown nodes.
One is this node here with the
node voltage vA and the second
node is the node with voltage
vT.
Let me start with vA and write
the node equation for that.
It is simply 1/L,
the node equation for this is
the current going in this
direction with is vI-vA integral
and that equals the current
going this way which is vA-v/R,
node equation.
I then write the node equation
for the node v,
for this node here,
and that is simply
(vA-v)/R=Cdvdt.
And that is what I have here,
two node equations.
Let me summarize the results
for you and then show you a view
graph where I grind through the
math as to how I got the result.
Here is the result I am going
to get.
If I take these two node
equations and I massage some of
the mathematics,
I am going to get this result.
And I will show you that in a
second.
By grinding through some math
and solving these two equations
and expressing this in terms of
v, I get a second order
differential equation,
d^2v blah, blah,
blah.
Notice that this is different
from the LC in this term.
Every step of the way you can
check to see if I am lying or I
am correct.
I will indulge you,
indulge myself rather with a
little story here.
Richard Fineman was a known
smart guy.
And one of the reasons that he
was that was in the middle of
talks he was known to get up and
ask some of the darndest,
hardest questions and say
ah-ha, you have a bug in this
proof here or a bug in this
equation that is not right.
And usually he would be
correct.
So his trick in doing this and
which is one reason how he
became a known smart guy.
What he would do is,
as the speaker went on talking
he would kind of follow along
and think of a simple initial
primitive case.
In this case,
I have an RLC circuit.
So think of a simpler case of
this.
A simpler case of this is R=0.
Whenever you set R to be zero,
you should get exactly what we
got in the last lecture,
correct?
That is what Fineman would do.
He would boil this down to a
simpler case,
make some assumptions and just
follow along.
And whenever he found a
discrepancy between the math
here and his simple case he
would say oh,
there is a bug there.
If you want you can catch me
that way.
Here, what Fineman would do is
replace R being zero,
and notice then this equation
here is exactly what we got the
last time with R being zero.
Just remember that Fineman
trick.
This is the equation we get,
the second-order differential
equation with an R term in
there.
And let me just grind through
the math and show you how I got
this from this.
So the two node equations
again.
And what I do is I start by
taking these two equations and
differentiating this with
respect to t and this is what I
get.
And, at the same time,
I have replaced (vA-v)/R here
by this term.
I replace this with this and
differentiate.
Then I simply divide the whole
thing by C.
Then I take this expression
here and write down vA is equal
to this stuff here.
Next I am going to substitute
this back for vA and eliminate
vA.
So I take this vA,
stick the sucker in here,
and thereby eliminate vA and
get this.
And then I simplify it and here
is what I get.
That is what I get.
I just grind through the two
equations and get that result.
So like a stuck record I will
repeat our mantra here,
which is here is how we solve
the equations that we run across
in this course,
the same three steps.
Find the particular solution.
Find the homogenous solution.
Find the total solution and
then find the constants using
the initial conditions.
Same steps.
You could recite this in your
sleep.
And the homogenous solution is
obtained using a further four
steps.
Let's just go through and apply
this method to our equation and
get the results.
vP is a particular solution and
vH is the homogenous solution.
With a particular solution,
oh.
Before I go on to do that,
let me set up my inputs and my
state variables.
My input is going to be a step.
Remember, I am trying to take
you to the point where the demo
left off.
The demo had a step input,
so I am going to use a step
input rising to vI.
And I am going to with the
initial conditions being all
zeros.
So the capacitor voltage is
zero, inductor current,
another state variable is also
zero, and therefore this is also
fondly called the ZSR or the
zero state response because
there is only an input but zero
state.
Again, remember the dashed
lines here.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
Let's start with a particular
solution.
This is as simple as it gets.
I simply write down the
particular equation and stick my
specific input.
And remember the solution to
the particular equation is any
old solution,
it doesn't have to be a general
solution, any old solution that
satisfies it.
And I am going to find a simple
solution here.
And V particular is a constant
VI.
It works.
Because remember this has been
working all along.
And I am going to keep pushing
this and see if this works until
the end of the course.
Guess what?
It will.
So this is a solution.
I'm done.
That is my particular solution.
Simple.
Second, I go and do my
homogenous solution.
And the homogenous equation,
remember, is the same old
differential equation with the
drive set to zero.
Remember that sometimes this
equation with the drive set to
zero is the entire equation you
have to deal with in situations
where you have zero input,
for example.
Or in other situations in which
you have an impulse at the
input.
And the impulse simply sets up
the initial conditions like a
charge in the capacitor or
something like that.
So we are going to blast
through this four-step method.
The method simply says that
four steps, I am going to assume
a solution of the form Ae^st.
And if you think you've seen
that before, yes,
you have seen it many times
before.
And you will see it again,
again and again.
And we need to find A and s.
We want to form the
characteristic equation,
find the roots of the equation
and then write down the general
solution to the homogenous
equation as this.
Same old same old.
Let me just walk through the
steps here.
Step A, assume a solution to
the form Ae^st.
And so I substitute Ae^st as my
tentative solution to the
equation.
Again, let me remind you that
the differential equations that
we solve here are really easy
because the way you solve them
is you begin by assuming you
know the solution and stick it
in and find out what makes it
work.
I am going to stick Ae^st into
this differential equation,
and A comes out here.
Differentiate this d squared,
I get s squared down here,
A s here and this simply gets
stuck down here with the 1/LC
coefficient.
The next step I begin
eliminating what I can,
so I eliminate the A's,
then eliminate the e^st's,
and I end up with this equation
here.
I end up with this equation.
This is my characteristic
equation.
It is an equation in s.
Do people remember the
characteristic equation we got
for the LC circuit?
Remember the Fineman trick?
That's right,
LC.
S^2+1/LC=0.
This thing wasn't there.
All you do is simply follow the
R.
Just follow the R.
Just imagine this is a dollar
sign and kind of follow it.
And you will see what the
differences are between the LC
and the RLC.
So this is the characteristic
equation.
What I am going to do,
iss much as I wrote the
characteristic equation for the
LC circuit, by substituting
omega nought squared for 1/LC.
Let me do the same thing here
but introduce something for R
and L as well.
What I will do is let me give
you this canonic form.
The very first second-order
equation I learned about when I
was a kid was this one,
S^2+2AS+B^2 or something like
that.
Let me write it in that form
where I get 2 alpha s plus omega
nought squared.
Again, remember the alpha comes
about because of R.
So omega nought squared is 1/LC
and alpha is RL/2.
Omega nought squared is 1/LC
and R/L is equal to two alpha.
I am just writing this in a
simpler form so that from now on
going forward I am just going to
deal with alphas and omega
noughts.
Once I get to this
characteristic equation,
after that I can give you one
generic way of solving it.
And depending on the kind of
circuit you have,
a series RLC,
which is what we have,
or a parallel RLC we will
simply get different
coefficients for the alpha term.
This is going to stay the same
but this term will look
different, alpha is going to
look different.
There is a real pattern here.
And what I am doing is simply
focusing on what is important,
what the differences are
between the pattern.
You learned the LC situation
and the RLC situation.
Given this I can now write
down, I am just simply replacing
this as my characteristic
equation in dealing with alphas
and omegas.
I will give you a physical
significance of alpha in a
little bit.
Do you remember the physical
significance of omega nought?
That was the oscillation
frequency.
In other words,
given an inductor and
capacitor, you put some charge
on the capacitor and you watch
it, it will oscillate.
And its oscillation frequency
will be one by a square root of
LC.
The magnitude of the initial
conditions will determine how
high are the oscillations or
what the phase is in terms of
when it starts,
but the frequency is going to
be the same.
Step three, to solve the
homogenous equation,
is find the roots of the
equation, s1 and s2,
and here are my roots.
Good old roots for a
second-order,
little s squared equation here.
Finally, given that I have the
roots, I can write down the
general homogenous solution.
So general solution is simply
A1e^s1t, A2e^s2t.
That's it.
That's the solution.
This looks big and corny,
but we are going to make some
simplifications as we go along
and show that it ends up boiling
down to something cos omega t.
The math is kind of involved
but we get down to something
very simple, a cosine.
Hold this general solution.
From that, as a step three of
the differential equation
solution, I write the total
solution down.
And my total solution is the
sum of the particular and the
homogenous, so therefore I get
this.
VI was my particular and this
term here is my homogenous
solution.
Now, if I wasn't doing circuits
and simply trying to solve this
mathematically here is what I
would do.
I would find the unknown from
the initial conditions,
so I know that v(0)=0.
And so therefore if I
substitute zero for V(0) I get
this.
If I substitute zero here,
t is 0, t is 0,
so I simply get V1+A1+A2.
And let me just blast through
because I am going to redo this
differently.
i=Cdv/dt.
And so that's what I get.
I substitute zero and this is
what I would get.
I hurried through this.
Don't worry.
I'm going to do it again.
If you just do it
mathematically,
you can solve this equation
here and these two simultaneous
equations in a1 and a2 and get
the coefficients and you are
done.
But it doesn't give us a whole
lot of insight into the behavior
of these terms here.
What I am going to do for now
is kind of ignore that.
Ignore I did that and instead
try to go down a path that is a
little bit more intuitive.
Let's stare at this expression
we got for the total solution.
That is the expression we got.
All I did is,
I had alpha in there,
I simply pulled out the alpha
outside.
So this is my total solution,
V1-A1e^(-alpha t) something
else and something else.
Three cases to consider
depending on the relative values
of alpha and omega nought.
If alpha is greater than omega
nought then I get a real
quantity here.
The square root of a positive
number, I get a real number,
and that number will add up to
the minus alpha and I am going
to get a solution that will look
like, oh, I'm sorry.
Let me just do it a little
differently.
There are three situations
here.
One is alpha greater than omega
nought.
Alpha equal to omega nought.
Alpha less than omega nought.
Alpha is greater,
alpha is less,
alpha is equal to this term
inside the square root sign.
For reasons you will understand
shortly, we call this
"overdamped" case,
the "underdamped" case and the
"critically damped" case.
When alpha is greater than
omega nought this term gives me
a real number,
and I get something as simple
as this.
Remember, for the series RLC
circuit, alpha was R/2L.
So if R is big,
in other words,
if in my RLC circuit R is huge
then I am going to get this
situation.
My output voltage on the
capacitor is going to look like
this, the sum of two
exponentials.
And if I were to plot it very
quickly for you,
for a VI step,
V would look like this.
So v would simply look like
this because it is the sum of a
couple of exponentials.
All right.
Now, alpha is positive here.
Remember alpha1 and alpha2 are
both positive.
These two added up,
because of this constant VI,
give rise to something that
increases in the following
manner.
Let's look at the situation
where alpha is less than omega
nought, where the term inside
the square root sign is
negative.
What I can do is pull the
negative sign out and express it
this way.
What I am going to do is since
alpha is less than omega nought,
I am going to reverse these two
and pull out square root of
minus one to the outside.
This is what I get.
I am just playing around with
this so that whatever is under
the square root sign ends up
giving me a positive real
number.
So I pull the j outside and
this is what I get.
Now, let me blast through a
bunch of math and end up with
something very,
very simple for this
underdamped case.
Let me define a few other
terms.
I am going to call omega nought
minus alpha squared the square
root of that.
I am going to call it omega d.
And here is what I get.
So I have defined three things
for you now, alpha,
omega nought and omega d.
And I get this equation in
terms of alpha and omega d.
And then, remember from your
good-old Euler relationship?
e to the j omega d is simply
cosine plus a j sine.
I am just going to blast
through a bunch of math rather
quickly.
Once I replace this in terms of
a cosine and sine,
cosine and a j sine and then
collect all the coefficients
together, I get an equation of
the form VI plus some constant e
to the minus alpha t,
cosine, the sum of the constant
e to the minus alpha t,
sine.
Remember the sines and cosines
are coming out,
but because of my R I am
getting this funny alpha here,
e to the minus alpha here.
So I am getting sums of sine
and cosine.
And K1 and K2 are some
constants which I will need to
determine for my initial
conditions.
I am going to continue on with
this and keep on simplifying it
because, as I promised you,
I want to get to something that
is just a cosine.
I want to go down this path.
I am not going to cover this
case, the critically damped
case.
And I will touch upon it later
but not dwell on it.
Let me continue down the path
of the underdamped case,
and this is what we have.
Continuing with the math,
let's start with the initial
conditions, v nought equals
zero, and that gives me K1 is
simply -VI.
So at v(0)=0 t is zero,
so this terms goes away,
the cosine becomes a 1,
e^(alpha t) goes away,
and K1=-VI.
Then I know that i(0) and i is
simply Cdv/dt.
And I get this nasty
expression.
I substitute t=0 and I get
something that looks like this.
I know what K1 is,
and so therefore K2 is simply
-V1alpha divided by omega
nought.
I have taken this expression
where the unknowns K1 and K2 are
to be found.
I set the initial conditions
down at t=0 and I get K1 and K2
as follows, which gives me the
following solution.
This is the solution I get
where I do not have any unknowns
anymore.
Remember that omega d and alpha
are directly related to circuit
parameters.
Alpha was R/2L and omega d was
square root of alpha squared
minus omega nought squared.
** omega d = sqrt(alpha^2 -
omega_0^2) **
And omega nought squared was 1
by square root of LC.
So I know it all now.
I still have sines and cosines
here, so I am going to simplify
this a little further.
Oh, before I go on to do that,
let's do the Fineman trick
again and notice if I am still
true to the LC circuit I did the
last time.
Remember when R goes to zero
alpha goes to zero.
Because alpha is R divided by
2L.
If alpha was zero what happens?
If alpha was zero,
this guy goes to one,
this whole term goes to zero
and omega dt now ends up
becoming omega nought,
and I get this term here.
I get VI-VIcosine(omega t),
which is exactly what I
expected in my equation.
This is the same as the LC case
that I got.
Let's go back to this situation
and simply if further.
If you look at Appendix B.7 in
your course notes,
Appendix B.7 is a quick
tutorial on trig.
And in that trig tutorial you
will see that,
and you have probably seen this
before, too, multiple times,
the scaled sum of sines are
also sines.
This is an incredibly cool fact
of sinusoids.
If you take two sinusoids of
the same frequency and you scale
them up in any which way and add
them up you also end up with a
sinusoid.
It is hard to believe but it is
true.
It is an incredible property of
sinusoids.
Take any two sinusoids,
scale them in any way you like,
same frequency,
add them up,
you will get a sinusoid.
What that is saying is that,
look, here is a sinusoid,
here is a sinusoidal function,
and I am scaling them up in
some manner.
So I should be able to add them
up and be able to express that
as single sine.
And to be sure you can,
look at the Appendix,
and there is an expression for
a1 sinX plus a2 cosX is equal to
a cosine of blah,
blah, blah.
This is what you get.
No magic here.
Just math.
From here I directly get this.
And look at what I have.
It is absolutely unbelievable.
v(t) is simply VI,
there is a constant here,
this an e to the minus alpha
term and there is a cosine.
Again, to pull the Fineman
trick, if this alpha were to go
to zero here then you would end
up with the expression you had
for the LC situation.
Let's stare at this a little
while longer.
There is a constant plus a
minus, a cosine term,
so there is a sinusoid at the
output, and there is an e to the
minus alpha which ends up giving
you the decay you have seen
before.
In other words,
to a step input,
the LC circuit would give you a
sinusoid.
That is what the LC circuit
would do if alpha was zero.
But because of this alpha term
here, e to the minus alpha t,
that gives rise to a damping
effect, so this causes this
thing to become smaller and
smaller as time goes by until
this term goes to zero at t
equals infinity.
This guy damps down and so
therefore you end up getting the
curve that you saw like this.
Twenty minutes of juggling math
solving a second-order
differential equation,
but what ends up is the same
sinusoid but it is damped in the
following manner such that the
frequency, rather the amplitude
keeps decaying until it starts
off at zero and then settles
down at vI.
This is exactly what you saw in
the demo that we showed you
earlier.
The critically damped case,
I am not going to do it here.
I am going to point you to the
following insight.
The underdamped case looked
like this.
It was a sinusoid that kind of
decayed out.
That is the underdamped case.
And then I showed you the
overdamped case.
The overdamped case looked like
this.
And, as you might expect,
the critically damped case is
kind of in the middle and looks
like this.
So the overdamped case would
look like this,
underdamped like this,
and the critically damped case
kind of goes up and kind of
settles down almost immediately.
This is when alpha equals omega
nought.
I won't do that case here,
but I will simply point you to
Section 13.2.3.
Just to tie things together,
recall this demo here that we
showed you in class yesterday.
This is exactly the kind of
form of the sinusoid you saw
because of that input step.
If you want to see a complete
analysis of inverter pairs and
look at the delays and so on
because of that,
you can look at Page 170 and
example 898.
In the next five or six
minutes, what I would like to do
is stare at the RLC circuit.
And much like I showed you some
intuitive methods to get the RC
response, what we are going to
do is do the same thing for the
RLC.
In the RLC situation,
much like the RC situation,
experts don't go around writing
15 pages of differential
equations and solving them each
time they see an RLC circuit.
They stare at it and boom,
the response pops out,
the sketch pops out.
This one is going to be another
one like our Bend it Like
Beckham series here.
And this one is in honor of
Leslie Kolodziejski.
And I call it "Konquer it like
Kolodziejski".
Again, as I said,
experts don't go around solving
long differential equations and
spending ten pages of notes
trying to get a sinusoid.
They look at a circuit and
sketch response.
I am going to show you how to
do that, too.
And what you can do is,
to practice,
go to Websim and try out
various combinations of inputs
and initial conditions and
sketch it, time yourself,
give yourself 30 seconds or a
minute if you like,
and sketch it and check it
against the Websim response.
If it doesn't match either you
are wrong or there is a bug in
Websim.
What I am going to do is,
the response to the critically
damped and underdamped case was
very easy to sketch out.
You started with an initial
condition, you settled at VI and
just kind of drew it like that.
The interesting case is the
underdamped case,
and that is what I am going to
dwell on.
Before we go on and I show you
the intuitive method,
as a first step I would like to
build some intuition.
Let's stare at this response
here and try to understand what
is going on.
This is the response that we
saw.
And this fact that you see an
oscillation happening is also
called "ringing".
You say that your circuit is
ringing.
All right.
You see some interesting facts.
You see that frequency of the
ringing is given by omega d.
This cosine omega d,
so that is the frequency omega
d.
So the time is 2 pi divided by
omega d.
The oscillation frequency is
omega d, but omega d is simply
omega nought squared minus alpha
squared.
Once you have a big value of R
alpha becomes very small and
omega d is very commonly equal
to, very close to omega nought.
So omega d and omega nought
very commonly are very close
together.
And when that happens this
frequency is directly omega
nought.
Alpha governs how quickly your
sinusoid decays.
e to the alpha t here is the
envelope that governs how
quickly my sinusoid decays.
And notice that each of these
terms, alpha and omega nought,
comes directly from my
characteristic equation.
Which means that once you get
your characteristic equation you
really don't have to do much
else.
And up until now you still have
to write the differential
equation to get the
characteristic equation,
so you still have to do some
differential equation stuff,
but in two lectures I am going
to show you a way that you can
even write down the
characteristic equation by
inspection.
Look at your circuit and boom,
in 15 seconds or less write
down the characteristic
equation.
It is absolutely unbelievable.
What are the other factors that
are interesting here?
Of course I need to find out
initial values.
I start off at zero.
This is my capacitor voltage.
If I don't have an infinite
spike or an impulse my capacitor
voltage tries to stay where it
is and starts off at zero.
And the final value is given by
VI, the capacitor is a long-term
open so therefore VI appears
across the capacitor.
In the long-term my final value
is going to be VI.
There is one other interesting
parameter, which I will simply
define today but dwell on about
a week from today,
and that is called the Q.
Some of you may have heard the
term oh, that's a high Q
circuit.
Q is an indication of how ringy
the circuit is.
And Q is defined as omega
nought by 2 alpha.
It is called the "quality
factor".
And it turns out that Q is
approximately the number of
cycles of ringing.
So if you have a high Q you
ring for a long time and if you
have a low Q you ring for a very
short time.
That is called the quality
factor defined by omega nought
by 2 alpha.
Notice that Q,
omega nought,
alpha, omega d,
all of these come from the
terms in the characteristic
equation.
We will spend more time on Q
later.
With this insight here is how I
can go about very quickly
sketching out the form of the
response.
Here is my circuit.
I want to sketch the form of
the response for a step input at
vI.
Zero to vI step input here,
I want to find out what happens
at this point.
This is described to you in a
lot more detail in Section 13.8
in your course notes.
Let's go through the steps.
Let's do the really simple
situation first.
Let's also assume for fun that
you are given that v(0) starts
out being some positive value.
Some v(0) which is a positive
number.
And, to make it harder on
ourselves, let's say i(0) starts
out being some negative number.
So i(0) is some negative
current.
The first thing I know is v(0),
the capacitor voltage starts
out here, which can change
suddenly.
And I also know that in the
long-term this is an open
circuit.
So that this voltage vI will
appear directly across the
capacitor in the long-term.
So I get starting out at v(0),
ending at vI,
I am also half the way there.
I know the initial and ending
point of the curve.
And then I know that somewhere
in here there must be some funny
gyrations here,
because remember I am dealing
with the underdamped case.
And you can determine that from
alpha and omega nought.
If alpha is less than omega
nought, you know that you are in
the underdamped case and this is
what you get.
Let's compute and write the
characteristic equation down.
A week from today you will
write it by inspection,
but for now you will do it by
writing down a differential
equation.
And from the characteristic
equation you will get omega d,
you will get alpha,
omega nought and Q.
So omega d gives you the
frequency of oscillations.
My frequency of oscillation is
now known.
From Q I know how long it
rings, because I know it rings
for about Q cycles.
I know that ringing stops
approximately here.
And then I know that between
that the start and end point my
curve kind of looks like this,
something like this.
Right there we are 95% of the
way there.
The only question is I do not
know if it goes like this or it
goes like this.
I am not quite sure yet if it
starts off going high or starts
off going low.
Not quite clear.
I also do not know what the
maximum amplitude is.
It turns out this is rather
complicated to determine so we
won't deal with that.
Just simply so you can draw a
rough sketch.
The questions is which way does
it start?
I could leave it for you to
think about.
Yeah, let me do that.
It is given on this page so
don't look at it.
Think about it,
and think about how you can
determine whether it goes up or
down.
It turns out that in this case
it is going to down and then
ring.
See if you can figure it out
for yourselves and then we will
talk about it next week.